j'adore la musique classique c'est
savoir je tiens ça de ma mère du coup à
jouer guillaume de la chaîne youtube
révisons nos classiques est venu parler
de son projet de grand concert qui m'a
proposé d'y participer et je dis bon
coup bon mais concrètement c'est quoi
cette histoire
le projet s'appelle arcadia d'une jolie
affiche sa est une grande soirée le 19
janvier 2018 donc sauvé la date et ça va
se passer au cirque d'hiver bouglione à
paris annonce ou pas de votre gueule moi
j'y serai avec les collègues
il y aura florence pourcel y aura à
peine de nota bene il y aura studio
braque et enfants de l'est hé oui paul y
aura aussi dit chan double oui c'est
vrai que c'est moins facile à dire alors
c'est vrai de quoi cette soirée d'abord
on va commencer par discuter un peu
faire des photos d elle fit des
dédicaces
c'est toujours sympa mais c'est après
que le truc vraiment poulard hume les
collègues les potes et moi on vous a
choisi les morceaux de musique classique
qui seront jouées ce soir là et nous on
sera sur scène pour vous expliquer
pourquoi on a pris ces morceaux là
plutôt que d'autres attention c'est pas
nous qui allons jouer ce sera un vrai
orchestre avec des vrais instrumentistes
et des vrais chanteurs je sais vraiment
c'est mieux voilà donc là on parle d'un
vrai concert de musique classique avec
des vrais morceaux cool mais je vous dit
pas lequel mais surtout c'est la
première fois que c'est organiser animer
y est programmée par youtube heures et
tout ça je vous le rappelle au cirque
d'hiver bouglione
c'est quand même pas mal de gueule bon
en plus du concert après concert il y
aura encore des trucs cool genre en
contrepartie de votre participation pour
nous aider à financer le projet parce
que oui on va demander un financement
participatif
c'est même déjà lancé tout ça se passe
sur la plateforme à d'artagnan point fr
évidemment je me l'adresse dans la barre
de description on a besoin de vous allez
jeter un oeil lâché un petit euro fait
un petit geste pour schématiser ya
plusieurs possibilités soit vous voulez
juste nous filer un coup de main pour
que ce projet voit le jour dans ce cas
là vous pouvez donner à partir de 5
euros
en plus ce sera un tirage au sort parmi
tous les gens qu'on donnait 5 euros et
le gagnant ou la gagnante pourra venir
assister gratuitement au concert et le
transport et l'hébergement seront
offerts si c'est qu'elles ont tous bien
de province donc c'est cool
autre possibilité vous voulez venir
assister au concert à paris voilà vous
pouvez acheter votre place et c'est
aussi sur d'artagnan point fr que ça se
passe ça commence à partir de 35 euros
il ya plein de pâques avec plein de
contrepartie différentes je vous laisse
aller regarder
voilà si vous avez envie de participer
si vous avez envie de soutenir le projet
si vous avez envie de venir assister au
grand concert à paris le 19 janvier 2018
je le rappelle vous le savez ce qui vous
reste à faire
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que moi
j'y serai et d'ici là qu'est ce que je
vous dis pas écouté mettez vous bien et
puis surtout portez vous bien